donc après le bilan généraliste de la
loi de programmation militaire 2019-2025
nous allons descendre davantage dans le
détail avec deux prochaines missions
flashs qui vont nous être présentées
dont la première est consacrée à la
défense solaire en France et en Europe
avec comme cours à porter nos collègues
Nathalie pouzireff et Jean-Louis et
thierio dans CV aux armées du 20 janvier
le Président de la République
définissait la défense solaire comme un
domaine à forte valeur ajoutée
opérationnelle
soulignons qu'elle représentait un enjeu
majeur pour nos armées ces cinq
prochaines années d'ailleurs le ministre
des armées à d'ores et déjà annoncé que
dans le projet de LPM il y aurait 5
milliards d'euros qui seraient consacrés
pour la période 2024 de 2030 en disant
je cite et qu'il fallait réinvestir ce
champ qui a été délaissé ces dernières
années et nos deux rapporteurs nous
précisons sans doute l'étendue et les
raisons de se délaissement ainsi que les
motifs de cette prise de conscience je
les remercie au passage pour leur
travail fourni puisqu'ils ont mené je
crois près d'une vingtaine d'auditions
et des nombreux déplacements jusque chez
partenaire check polonais ou italien
nous serons bien entendu très attentifs
pour écouter vos analyses et connaître
vos différentes recommandations que vous
formulerez en prévision de la prochaine
votre programmation militaire afin de
renforcer et adapter nos capacités de
défense solaire chers collègues je vous
laisse la parole
merci monsieur le président
chers collègues
nous sommes ravis Jean-Louis kerriot et
moi-même de vous présenter ce matin les
conclusions de notre mission
d'information flash sur la défense
solaire en France et en Europe et qui se
déroulera suivant quatre parties donc
une première introduction et rappel du
contexte dans lequel nous avons mené
cette mission un état des lieux
en troisième partie les besoins associés
à la LPM et quatrième et dernière partie
la préparation de l'avenir les futurs
enjeux et les recommandations
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président nous avons tenu à mettre à
profit au maximum le peu de temps qui
nous était imparti parce que c'est une
mission flash pour réaliser ce travail
et nous avons conduit donc une vingtaine
d'auditions qui ont rassemblé une
trentaine d'interlocuteurs en provenance
de nos forces des industriels de
l'armement ces auditions nous ont
contribué à nourrir notre réflexion à
enrichir le rapport et à inspirer ses
conclusions comme le sujet le sujet le
nom de la mission la protection du
territoire et la sécurisation de
l'espace aérien sans visage évidemment
dans un cadre régional en concertation
avec nos alliés européens c'est pourquoi
les déplacements que nous avons
effectués en République tchèque en
Pologne et en Italie faisait partie
intégrante de cette mission et nous ont
permis d'enrichir notre analyse ainsi
que d'éclairer la pertinence de
l'initiative du Bouclier européen your
pian skyfield initiative autrement dit
et si qui a été porté par l'Allemagne
alors avant de passer à l'état des lieux
quelques points de contexte dans lequel
s'est déroulée cette mission
premièrement
la guerre en Ukraine comme l'avait fait
précédemment l'affrontement ou au Caraba
a confirmé l'émergence de nouvelles
menaces telles que les attaques
saturantes les essaims de drone et les
missiles hyperbellos
la guerre en Ukraine témoigne ainsi de
l'intérêt de déposer de disposer d'une
défense solaire multicouche pour se
prémunir de l'ensemble des menaces
aériennes elle a d'ailleurs montré son
efficacité en déniant l'accès du ciel à
l'armée de l'air russe pourtant en
supériorité numéraire ce qui explique en
partie que les notamment que les
affrontements se poursuivent au sol
ce sont jusqu'à 200 missiles par jour
qui ont pu être tirés par la défense
solaire en Ukraine
autrement dit les forces armées
ukrainiennes consomment en un jour ce
qui est potentiellement fabriqué en un
an par les industries de la défense
alliés vous comprendrez aisément que
toutes les chaînes de production soient
aujourd'hui mise sous pression
autre point de contexte
il ne vous a pas échappé que
l'initiative du Bouclier européen
européenne
lancée par l'Allemagne avec créer une
certaine surprise pour ne pas dire à
mécontentement de la partie française
15 pays ont adhéré
donc or Italie et Pologne et parmi ces
pays certains
s'accordent à dire que le besoin est
réel mais que cette initiative
correspond davantage à une sorte de
centrale d'achat de mutualisation des
achats et pour l'Allemagne une façon
d'allouer une partie des 100 millions
100 milliards
consacrés à son fond spécial de défense
mais bien sûr on peut lire aussi
l'ambition de l'Allemagne de ce hic au
rang d'intégrateur et l'ambition de deal
de la société deal de SEIC comme
missiliez mon collègue Jean-Louis
Thiriot aura l'occasion de revenir sur
l'impact de cette initiative sur la BITD
néanmoins ce qui nous apparaît une
questionne concernant la pertinence de
cette initiative européenne skyfield
c'est que premièrement il utilise de
prétendre garantir une protection à
l'ensemble d'un territoire en le mettant
sous une bulle face à l'ensemble des
menaces de la troisième dimension
en effet il s'agit de privilégier une
différence une défense de points ou de
théâtre
deuxièmement parce qu'elle fait
l'impasse
sur les systèmes d'armement développés
en Europe
par exemple santé ou autrement appelé
Mamba qui a été développé entre la
France l'Italie la Grande-Bretagne qui
est un système parfaitement
interopérable avec le temps
le Mika à lancement vertical ou bien le
Mistral
et enfin parce que l'introduction
éventuelle du missile israélien arrow 3
qui n'est pas interopérable avec la
chaîne de commandement de l'OTAN
n'est pas en phase avec la doctrine
stratégique de défense anti-missile
balistique or l'OTAN reste le pilier de
la défense collective de l'Europe
à cet égard la position de la France
dans l'OTAN
concernant la défense antimissiles
balistique donc que l'on appelle aussi
des amb et conforme à la déclaration du
sommet de Chicago en 2012 qui met en
avant une
défense antimicile logistique de théâtre
et non de territoire
à ce titre la France contribue de
manière régulière à la DMB de l'Alliance
comme c'est actuellement le cas avec un
système santé donc c'est le solaire
moyenne portée en version terrestre qui
est déployée actuellement en Roumanie
plus généralement l'OTAN opère la même
distinction que la France entre
dissuasion nucléaire et défense solaire
dernier point de contexte avant de céder
la parole à mon collègue permettez-moi
de porter à votre attention l'enjeu très
particulier que nous autorités auront à
relever à l'occasion des Jeux Olympiques
et paralympique de
2024 à Paris la sécurisation aérienne et
la lutte antidrone autrement dénommée
lad elle a des luttenty drone de cet
événement permettra à la France d'être
un acteur de référence dans le domaine
les premières livraisons de nouveaux
systèmes de lutte anthydrone parade sont
prévues pour cette année
opérationnel pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby et un démonstrateur d'armes laser
sera disponible en 2024 mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir dans nos
recommandations
aussi venons-en maintenant à l'objet de
cette mission premier objet qui est de
faire un état des lieux de la défense
solaire en Europe et de questionner le
niveau des moyens alloués par la France
à la veille de l'examen de cette
nouvelle LPM
cher Natalia monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues avant d'entrer dans le
cœur du sujet c'est-à-dire cette état
des lieux pardon si j'en réveille
certains
avant d'entrer dans cet état des lieux
je veux d'abord vous dire tout le
plaisir que nous avons eu Natalia et
moi-même à travailler ensemble et
c'était l'enrichissement de deux visions
l'ingénieur et littéraire et le juriste
et la rencontre des deux ça a permis je
crois de travailler très utilement parce
que je ne vous cache pas que parfois
quand on allait sur des considérations
techniques de capteurs j'étais heureux
d'avoir
Natalia à mes côtés alors avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet c'est-à-dire cet
état des lieux il faut toujours partir
de définition penser clairement c'est
d'abord définir et distinguer quand on
parle de DSA de quoi parle-t-on
exactement il s'agit de faire face à
toutes les menaces qui viennent de la
troisième dimension sur les forces ou
sur le territoire il peut s'agir de
missile balistiques intercontinentaux
les ICBM de missile balistique de
théâtre tels que les scudes bien connu
de missiles de croisière de missiles
d'avion d'hélicoptère ou de drones elle
doit se distinguer en couche la défense
bascouche de quelques kilomètres à
quelques centaines de mètres de la cible
de défense à moyenne portée ou de
défense à longue portée
l'interception peut être endos ou
exo-atmosphérique cette dernière n'étant
pas pratiquée par les puissantes
européennes seuls les Américains la
pratique avec le système TAD
la nature du vecteur offensif lui-même
ne préjuge pas de la nature de
l'interception le choix ou la nécessité
peuvent dicter d'intercepter en basse
couche un missile pourtant tirer de loin
une DSA efficace est nécessairement
multicouche elle suppose plusieurs
outils des capteurs pour détecter
attribués et définir la menace des
efflecteurs pour la neutraliser un C2
pour coordonner les feux elle porte sur
la défense des points sensibles la
protection de portion du territoire ou
celle du corps de bataille au plus près
de l'ennemi
un point doit d'ores et déjà être
précisé la France puissance dotée de
l'arme nucléaire considère qu'une
attaque balistique par ni si
l’intercontinentaux relève des intérêts
vitaux et donc de la dissuasion c'est
pourquoi dans cette étude nous avons
exclu la problématique de l'interception
des ICBM et d'ailleurs je précise nous
avons aussi fait le choix eu égard au
caractère limité d'une mission flash de
ne pas traiter de la défense solaire
dans l'espace maritime donc je m'en
excuse auprès du marin et entend quand
c'est officier de marine de réserve vous
voyez je suis capable de raisonner
au-delà des limites de la casquette
donc voyons la situation en France
maintenant avant tout il faut préciser
un point de doctrine parce qu'il n'est
de systèmes d'armes que dans le cadre
d'une doctrine notre doctrine c'est la
dissuasion elle est centrée sur sa
crédibilité
la défense solaire se limite à
l'interception d'une menace
conventionnelle elle est une capacité de
défendre une zone ou des points
sensibles les capacités solaires ont
pour mission de garantir cette
permanence et cette crédibilité de la
dissuasion en protégeant d'abord les
sites nécessaires à son exercice
elles ont une seconde mission qui est
d'éviter un contournement par le bas
c'est à dire des attaques sous le seuil
des intérêts vitaux pour permettre au
chef des armées le président de la
République d'élargir la palette de ses
réactions possibles et ce que je dis
n'est pas abstrait imaginons quelques
missiles balistiques type Scud tirés par
des proxy sur le sud de la France depuis
des zones grises du sud de la
Méditerranée on pense notamment à la
Libye dont on sait que c'est un trou
noir géopolitique il serait difficile
d'imaginer une riposte nucléaire surtout
si les auteurs étaient des proxy non
identifiés où il ne soit pas facile
d'attribuer la TAC dès lors la déesse ça
et bien là pour épauler l'addition par
les moyens conventionnels
ces éléments étant posés voyons les
moyens dont dispose la France soyons
clairs depuis 25 ans la défense solaire
a connu un désengagement capacitaire et
financier cette situation résulte de
l'appréciation des menaces et de la
nature des opérations
engagées nos armées ont été engagées sur
des théâtres où la supériorité aérienne
dans des conflits asymétriques étaient
toujours assurés d'ailleurs il ne
s'agissait même pas que de supériorité
il s'agissait à l'époque de suprématie
aujourd'hui le monde a changé nous avons
basculé vers des hypothèses de combat de
haute intensité lorsque ici dans cette
commission il y a un an avec notre
collègue Patricia mirales nous avons
nous avions présenté notre rapport sur
la défense de haute intensité nous
avions déjà identifié ces trous
capacitaires en matière de défense
solaire il est bien évident que les
événements façon ne font que renforcer
cette analyse
bien conduite cette défense
anti-aérienne et d'une efficacité
redoutable depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les pertes aériennes ont été
essentiellement causées par les défenses
solaires adverses dans les conflits de
haute intensité et non l'aviation de
chasse compense à deux épisodes
bien connus ceux de la guerre du Vietnam
ou de la guerre du Kippour ou la chasse
américaine ou la chasse ou les avions de
l'embardement israélien ont été victimes
des missiles de défense solaire vous
trouverez dans notre rapport une analyse
complète de la déesse ça en Ukraine
quelques mots sur ce texte en Ukraine la
supériorité aérienne est acquise par
aucun adversaire même dans un espace et
pour un temps déterminé c'est ce qui
aboutit à l'enlisement du conflit
puisque la manœuvre
semestre est bloqué lorsque cette
supériorité n'est pas acquise car la
supériorité aérienne est la condition
nécessaire à la liberté d'action et à la
manœuvre
si les interceptions ukrainiennes
atteignent un niveau élevé on parle
d'environ 80 % le concept expose le
conflit expose d'abord les limites du
concept de défense de territoire face
aux effets de saturation elle reste
incapable de défendre convenablement une
grande étendue il est illusoire de
prétendre garantir une protection à
l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien
d'ailleurs même le Dôme de fer israélien
protège des points d'intérêt il ne
protège pas la
totalité du territoire ce ROTEX conforte
notre approche française privilégiant la
défense solaire de si toutes théâtre dès
lors et un des éléments majeurs de ce
conflit c'est le rôle très important de
l'artillerie solaire les canons entières
notamment les guépards fournis par les
Allemands qui sont guidé
par radar ont obtenu d'excellents
résultats qu'il s'agisse de la lutte
entière aérienne ou de la lutte contre
les
hélicoptères ou les
aéronefs cependant nous devons avoir en
tête ce conflit ukrainien mais notre
rôle à tous est de ne pas faire de ce
conflit le seul paradigme des combats
futurs il y a d'autres combats qui
peuvent nous attendre et d'autres
théâtres qui peuvent être menaçants et
la France puissance d'équilibre avec un
S si j'ai bien compris mais puissance
globale à vocation à les traiter
dans notre pays le choix a été fait de
confier le pilotage de toute la défense
contre les menaces de la troisième
dimension à l'armée de l'air ce n'est
pas le cas partout il y a aujourd'hui
encore des pays où la répartition avec
l'armée de terre est n'est pas encore
arbitré pas tranché aujourd'hui le
commandement c'est l'Armée de l'Air
ensuite
l'armée de terre est amené à opérer dans
des box qui lui ont été confiées pour la
défense bascouche pour assurer cette
défense notre pays dispose aujourd'hui
en moyenne et haute couches de 8
systèmes
ça me PEM en bas de 12 unités crottes et
d'une défense solaire de l'armée de
terre sur laquelle je vais un peu
assister parce que c'est là où les trous
capacitaires sont les plus frappants
aujourd'hui notre défense solaire
dispose de 10 batteries au sol très
courte portée équipée de Mistral
affectés au 54e régiment
d'artillerie de Hyères et de 6 batteries
intégrées à des régiments d'infanterie
de l'air c'est d'ailleurs le même
régiment qui emploie également le
système arlad de lutte anthydrone nous
devons avoir à l'esprit et ça sera un
des enjeux de la LPM et un des enjeux
majeurs de ce rapport que cette défense
solaire de théâtre a été massivement
sous investi en 2002 nous avions encore
quatre régiments d'artillerie solaire
nous n'en n'avons plus qu'un les
véhicules sont anciens les radars ne
sont pas tridimensionnels il est prévu
d'avoir des commandes de radar Thalès
mais c'est une excité et il n'existe
plus d'artillerie solaire digne de ce
nom il ne reste que quelques 20 mm sur
des vabs anciens
cependant et c'est notre fierté la
France est l'un des rares pays à avoir
maintenu une série complète de capacités
aussi bien de manière opérationnelle que
de manière industrielle avec nos
missiles mistrales de MBDA nos missiles
crottale de MBDA est à la S et notre
santé de même BDA et Thalès c'est à la
fois la vertu d'un modèle
échantillonnaire c'est aussi ses limites
puisque face à un combat de haute
intensité se pose la question
des volumes et des stocks par ailleurs
et je tiens à insister là-dessus notre
pays possède
de nombreuses pépites dans le domaine de
la lutte anthydrone la l.a.d qui est
évidemment un enjeu majeur il s'agit des
grandes entreprises des grands
ensembliers comme Thalès mais il s'agit
aussi de jeunes entreprises susceptibles
de devenir
les licornes de demain je pense dans le
laser à Silas qui aujourd'hui est déjà
une société mature ou à une start-up du
Nord NC2 qui fait un travail absolument
remarquable dans le brouillage dans la
lutte anthydrone et qui a un rôle très
important à jouer à l'avenir et nous
pouvons en être fiers et c'est
l'occasion de saluer ces entreprises
concernant la situation en Europe nous
avons fait un tableau dans le rapport
donc je vous inviterai à
vous y reportez il faut distinguer les
nations de têtes système américain
moyenne porté tels que les patriotes
avec des pays comme les Pays-Bas
l'Allemagne la Grèce l'Espagne la
Pologne la Roumanie la Suède et la
Suisse deux pays dotés d'anciens
matériels de l'Union soviétique avec des
moyens limités pour les remettre à
niveau et de pays qui confient leur
protection
solaire à l'alliance faute de moyens cet
état des lieux est opposé vu le court
temps de réaction face à une menace
aérienne c'est naturellement le
dispositif de protection collective de
l'OTAN qui supposerait activités
interopérabilité et efficacité qui
permet d'assurer la sécurité de l'Europe
il n'y aurait pas de sécurité collective
de l'Europe sans une présence de tous
les pays européens dans l'ère commande
and contrôle système situé à Ramstein en
Allemagne je souhaite souligner à la
fois cette efficacité mais aussi le fait
que l'alliance souffre d'un déficit
capacitaire important du fait du
non-respect des engagements et efforts
consentis par les alliés dans le cadre
de cette mission il y a urgence à
renforcer l'efficacité des systèmes à ce
jour notre pays honneur c'est cible
capacitaire mais elles vont devoir être
revues dans le cadre du processus de
planification et de Défense de l'OTAN
avec évidemment une nécessité de
remonter en puissance
état des lieux faits quels sont les
enjeux pour la France les enjeux
de la DSA pour la prochaine LPM
le 3 priorités qui seront a priori
traités je pense bien traiter avec
l'annonce des 5 milliards prévus dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire c'est un effort massif devront
être
honoré ces trois priorités c'est d'abord
la remise à niveau de notre DSA
bascouche avec le développement d'une
artillerie solaire de théâtre digne de
ce nom aujourd'hui nos industriels avec
Nexter et le rapide fire un canon de 40
mm sont
[Musique]
pardonnez moi en pointe sur ce sujet
des financements doivent encore
aujourd'hui être trouvés pour développer
les munitions herbustes qui permettent
de tirer un halo de munitions un peu
comme une cartouche de fusil de chasse
attaqué à adapter à la défense de
l'avant et à la lutte contre les petits
objets les drones et les attaques
saturentes le retour du canon est le
seul moyen de traiter ces menaces
saturentes deux types drones et cela un
coût acceptable l'un des enjeux majeurs
de la défense solaire c'est de ne pas
tirer un missile Mistral à 150000 euros
pour faire face à un drone à 2000 euros
et cela le canon seul permet de le faire
nous avons là un enjeu euh
opérationnel pour nos troupes nous avons
un enjeu industriel avec ce ces
munitions enfin se produit nexters qui
supposerait et ça va être une bataille
qui va falloir mener au sein de l'auto
que le commandement de l'avenir qui est
détenu aujourd'hui par un poste est
occupé par un Français fait façade
maître le standard 40 mm comme standard
au temps ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui en dehors de la marine mais
j'avais mis le sujet marine de côté il
faut que ça devienne aussi un standard
autant terrestre pour arriver à avoir la
possibilité de le développer j'attire
vraiment l'attention sur ce segment de
la défense de théâtre car c'est un
élément essentiel de la protection de
nos forces qu'il s'agisse de points fixe
tels que des états majeurs ou qu'il
s'agisse d'unités en mouvement
aussi un élément de réassurance morale
pour nos troupes qui sont engagées au
plus près de l'ennemi rien n'est plus
terrible que d'être bombardé sans
pouvoir réagir et on se souvient que
l'efficacité des stocks pendant la
guerre de 40 était au moins autant les
fêtes paniques engendrées
par les avions que les désordres
cinétiques causés par les bombardements
et donc nous recommandons de
renforcer fortement cette défense
solaire
pour les forces terrestres en ex soit en
renforçant le 54e régiment d'artillerie
qui existe aujourd'hui soit
éventuellement en recréant un deuxième
régiment autre enjeu remplacé
progressivement les systèmes crotale à
partir de 2026 avec la solution VL mica
qu'évoquait ma collègue Natalia enfin
face aux enjeux nouveaux il est
nécessaire de c'est le volume de nos
batteries
santé en passant au moins de 8 à 12
batteries sachant qu'entre la protection
de la dissuasion la protection de
quelques points fixes et la nécessité
éventuellement de créer une bulle
au-dessus de force nous sommes
aujourd'hui à l'os et ce sera évidemment
une priorité
enfin il y a les éléments de la lutte
anthydrone qui mériterait un rapport
complet simple élément à avoir en tête
la France avec les JO et Natalia en a
parlé et très en pointes sur le sujet
qui s'agisse du C2 ou qu'il s'agisse de
des efflecteurs du développement des
armes à énergie dirigées ce serait
évidemment un enjeu de l'avenir
concernant l'Europe et je finirai
là-dessus à l'échelle européenne nous
avons besoin d'une des françaises
sur des enjeux aussi importants on a
besoin d'une BITD européenne et donc il
faut renforcer nos partenariats et nos
coopérations industrielles pour coopérer
il faut être plusieurs et il faut que
tout le monde le souhaite c'est pour ça
que je vais achever en parlant un peu
plus longuement de l'initiative
allemande de du européenne skychi
c'était présenté comme un projet
européen et un engagement enfin de
l'Allemagne dans l'Europe de la défense
et dans l'autonomie stratégique ce
projet a été présenté par nos voisins
d'outreins lors du discours de Prague du
29 août 2022 sans même que la France
officiellement le plus proche partenaire
de l'Allemagne ne soit mentionné dans le
discours
inutile d'insister que cela n'était pas
particulièrement
amicale aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
pays la Pologne le Danemark la Suède
l'Italie n'ont pas pris part à cette
initiative il ne s'agit pas d'un
bouclier européen puisque il n'y a pas
de réflexion stratégique derrière il n'y
a pas de stratégie de C2 c'est d'abord
une mutualisation des achats de système
de défense solaire avec trois
efflecteurs envisagés
l'irisé allemand le patriote américain
et la ro3 israélo-américain premier
élément laro 3 n'est pas compatible au
temps quant aux autres ce sont des
missiles certes compatibles autant mais
dont il faut garder à l'esprit que le
projet et que ce soit les Allemands qui
soient en charge soit d'une production
sudiste sous licence soit en tout cas du
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
des
missiles soyons clairs cette initiative
n'est qu'une réponse partielle et était
un refus assumé de contribuer à
développer une souveraineté européenne
puisque nous avons un missilier de
grande qualité à travers MDBA qui est je
rappelle français italien et allemand et
qu'on a même pas mis et britannique
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit allemand et
britannique et on a même pas demandé
AMDA de participer à ce projet
évidemment britannique à travers BAE en
clair il s'agit d'une réponse symbolique
que l'Allemagne a sans doute voulu faire
pour répondre à son aveuglement
face à la menace russe face aux liens
qu'elle a lentement retenue avec les
entreprises russes face à la dépendance
au gaz russe bref nous l’interprétons
comme beaucoup
d'analystes de la situation en Allemagne
comme le désir de se racheter une
virginité politique vis-à-vis de ses
voisins de l'Est assortis de l'illusion
de prendre une initiative politique la
réalité c'est du symbolique c'est aussi
une stratégie industrielle et
commerciale dont ni la France ni
l'Europe ne doivent être dues
la France par ailleurs doit développer
d'autres partenariats et je tiens à
souligner l'accueil exceptionnel qui
nous a été réservé à Natalia et à moi
par nos partenaires italiens nous
connaissons la force de MDBA qui a pris
une place de leader européen dans le
domaine des missiles moyennes portées
avec le SAM P T et le nouveau sambt NG
vous avez vu la commande de 700 missiles
qui vient d'être passé nous venons
d'avoir la mise en oeuvre du traité de
kirinal qui est absolument cruciale
entre la France et l'Italie il y a une
volonté de travailler avec la France et
je crois que c'est un des axes sur
lesquels notre commission doit
travailler
nous partageons avec nos amis italiens
la même préoccupation stratégique de la
Méditerranée les Italiens l'appellent la
Méditerranée élargie qui va du détroit
d'hermouse au détroit de Gibraltar et de
la Méditerranée orientale au golfe de
Guinée en intégrant le Sahel et c'est
vraiment un point sur lequel je tiens à
assister voilà je ne serai pas plus long
je veux simplement dire que pour
répondre à ces défis il faut répondre à
deux défis en même temps parfois
contradictoire celui du temps court dont
sont habitées nos partenaires d'Europe
de l'est parce que la menace est à leur
proche est à leur porte ils sont dans
l'urgence beaucoup d'interlocuteurs que
nous avons entendu en Tchécoslovaquie
encore plus en Pologne nous disent vous
nous parlez d'une BITD à 20 ans nous
nous serons peut-être en guerre dans
deux ans donc c'est vrai que la
perception n'est pas la même inversement
les menaces ne se limitent pas à la
menace à l'Est nous avons besoin d'une
vision de long terme sur d'autres
théâtres notamment le flan sud et nous
avons aussi besoin pour une véritable
autonomie stratégique qui ne soit pas
d'un concept creux d'une BITD commune
construite à long terme et le rôle du
politique c'est d'articuler ces deux
séquences temporelles qui peuvent
paraître délicates à concilier et je
passe la parole à Natalia pour achever
cette exposition
merci
merci Jean-Louis donc vous avez vu nous
sommes parfaitement raccords sur les
points de contexte et après il suffit
que j'appuie sur le bouton pour lancer
la machine tirio et c'est parti bon
alors voilà je vais rebondir reprendre
là où on en était c'est à dire sur la
préparation
de l'avenir je ne serai pas exhaustive
parce que voilà on va laisser le temps
aux questions aussi mais j'insisterai
sur trois points premièrement le défi
posé par la menace hyper vélos alors en
premier lieu celle des planeurs
hypersoniques propulsé dans l'espace par
leur booster à des vitesses extrêmement
importantes les planeurs peuvent
rebondir sur plusieurs couches hautes de
l'atmosphère zone dans lesquelles il est
très difficile aujourd'hui de les
repérer et de les intercepter par des
systèmes de défense même les plus
sophistiqués ils sont ensuite
manœuvrables jusqu'à la zone d'impact
lutter contre cette menace la menace des
planeurs hypersoniques nécessitent la
maîtrise de technologie réservée aux
puissances nucléaires
les études sont en cours donc en France
pour identifier les technologies et
moyens permettant de contrer ces
nouvelles menaces
en revanche une capacité initiale
d'interception de cible hypersoniques en
phase terminale et déjà prise en compte
dans le cas de l'évolution du sante de
nouvelles générations santé donc c'est
le solaire moyen de porter terrestre
grâce à aux nouveaux vecteurs alors
excusez-moi des termes c'est un peu les
données missions sont un peu compliquées
c'est le missile Aster dans sa version
B1 NT EC
combiné ou successeur du radar de
conduite à Abel et dont la mise en
service est prévue à l'horizon 2027 donc
déjà cette capacité là
antimissiles hypersonique est prise en
compte par la France
l'étape suivante s'appelle le standard
OC2
consisterait à y adjoindre un radar de
détection avancée type UHF qui permet de
voir loin et des petites cibles pour
disposer bien sûr d'un temps de réaction
plus long parce que plus la menace
qui arrive et rapide plus il faut être
en capacité de le détecter loin pour
avoir une réactivité la réactivité
suffisante
ensuite
dans la préparation de l'avenir toujours
et en termes d'alerte avancée justement
il existe le projet twister c'est un
projet de la CSP de la coopération
structurée permanente
Twitter ça veut dire timely warning à
interception whispace Theater
surveillance
c'est un donc un projet de la
coopération structure et permanente de
l'Union européenne Union européenne qui
s'appuie sur deux piliers l'intercepteur
et l'alerte avancée spatiale
en matière d'intercepteur en doit
atmosphérique
donc là on parle du vecteur le projet
européen aidef your pian high personic
defense Interceptor a été retenu pour le
Fond Européen de défense sous la
coordination du groupe espagnol sénère
contre le projet concurrent
IDIS de MBDA
MBDA a d'ailleurs fait un recours qui a
été publié au Journal officiel de
l'Union européenne le 9 janvier dernier
en effet l’articulation entre la
coopération structurée permanente qui
est dans la main
des étapes puisque c'est un au Conseil
européen donc on est dans le domaine de
l'intergouvernementale
et le fait d'être cet articulation donc
CSP et def
n'est pas assuré
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avions
évoqué c'est un risque que nous avions
évoqué dans le rapport sur la
coopération structure et permanente que
nous avons remis lors du mandat
précédent avec ma collègue Michel
thaboro
et l'attribution de marché qui a été
faite sur le fedf elle est dans les
mains de la Commission et la Commission
a plutôt tendance à suivre les règles de
la mise en concurrence sans
considération à notre sens de la
crédibilité industrielle du projet et en
prenant d'ailleurs le risque d'une
fragmentation industrielle sinon à quoi
bon d'avoir des champions européens
deuxième
élément
prometteur pour le futur
mon collègue la bien sûr précisé la
lutte antidrone
est un point essentiel de la différence
maintenant solaire
dans nos armées et si on doit prévoir
une évolution il faut savoir que les
futurs drones petite cible aujourd'hui
elles sont elles sont téléguées elles
pourront devenir autonome et face à cela
il est intéressant de développer ce
qu'on appelle les AED les armes à
énergie dirigées
en effet leur première application sont
envisagées face aux petits drones
elles sont une façon de répondre à
l'évolution de la menace qui sera
marquée par une insensibilité croissante
au brouillage
et elles pourront apporter une réforme
une réponse efficace aux menaces à bas
coût envoyé en nombre par leur coûts et
la possibilité de répétitivité des
interceptions dans ce domaine la France
s'intéresse à la fois aux armes laser et
aux armes électromagnétiques avec des
feuilles de route technologiques qui
sont déjà engagées
troisième point
la France doit d'être dans la course qui
mène à l'avènement du combat
collaboratif
par
combattif on peut envisager par exemple
l'intercolelectivité entre une défense
solaire et le Rafale
aujourd'hui on sait que le F35 est déjà
un c'est de volant il devait en être
même du futur système SCAF donc il
faudra bien que l'on s'inscrive dans la
préparation d'une architecture qui sera
suffisamment ouverte pour être
interopérable
mais aussi robuste donc bien sûr ça
paraît de notions antinomiques et c'est
là où toutes les toutes les la beauté de
l'enjeu
je terminerai en présentant rapidement
les principales recommandations issues
de notre mission
au vu de tous les éléments évoqués plus
haut nous appelons de nos vœux pour la
prochaine LPM vous l'aurez compris le
réinvestissement dans la défense solaire
et un effort indispensable en termes de
volumétrie capacitaire cela était dit
actuellement 8 sections de
santé Mamba sont disponibles la cible
doit être revalorisée en passant à 12
sections le remplacement du crottin
devra se faire lors de son retrait en
service dès 2026
deuxième enjeu deuxième recommandation
pour suivre la modernisation nécessaire
du santé NG par le standard
OC2 comme je l'ai mentionné tout à
l'heure par l'adjonction d'un radar
UHF indispensable pour suivre
l'évolution de la menace par exemple
celle de missile balistique à tête
séparable troisième recommandation
renforcer la capacité de veille et de
détection de la défense
solaire l'efficacité de notre défense
solaire vous l'aurez compris repose donc
sur la capacité à coordonner les
différentes briques la menace doit être
d'abord identifiée avant d'être
attribuée au meilleur système
d'interception la capacité de détection
autonome au dessus de notre territoire
et d'ailleurs complété par une
interconnexion avec un certain nombre de
radars européens sur la base d'accord
binationaux ou dans le cadre de l'OTAN
poursuivre cette intégration renforcera
notre capacité
la France aussi doit
œuvrer pour être à l'initiative proposer
des initiatives capacitaires au temps
je soulignerai
la nécessité d'avoir une vision
multicouche intégrée et cohérente du
commande contrôle qui est un programme
de l'OTAN mais sur lequel on travaillait
la JV Thalès rater
quatrième point
il conviendrait de mettre en place un
centre de commandement et de contrôle
avec une vision unique des règles
d'engagement précises et partagées par
l'ensemble des pays membres de l'OTAN en
effet la décision d'engagement suppose
un important travail préalable de
définition des responsabilités
politiques et juridiques
cinquième point accompagner la manœuvre
des forces terrestres et renforcer leur
protection notamment par la mise en
oeuvre de capacités mobiles sous
blindage et 6ème point redonner à
l'artillerie un rôle longtemps négligé
dans la défense solaire je crois que mon
collègue a eu le temps de l'exposer
précédemment
dernier point répondre bien sûr au défi
de la lutte antidrone et plus
particulièrement en termes de ressources
humaines
la lutte anthydrone pour le 14 juillet
c'est une veille de 24 heures pour la
Coupe du monde de rugby en 2023 ce sera
200 heures pour
les Joop 2024 on va passer à 4000 4000
heures donc vous voyez l'impact que ça
peut avoir en terme de renouvellement
des personnels qui seront en charge de
la lutte antidrone postée en zone
urbaine pour conclure mes chers
collègues nous nous réjouissons que la
défense solaire soit de nouveau une
capacité priorité prioritaire pour les
Américains françaises puisque le
ministre des Armées l'a annoncé nous
comptons investir 5 milliards d'euros
sur la période 2024-2030 et nous
espérons en ce sens que nous
recommandations seront entendues je vous
remercie mes chers collègues pour votre
attention ainsi que celle que nous a
accompagnées Caroline dépasse Nostrad
administratrice et
ise qui était la stagiaire auprès
merci à tous les deux pour votre travail
alors nous avons cette demande
d'intervention et une trentaine de
minutes de vent nous donc je demanderai
aux orateurs de groupe si possible de se
limiter à deux minutes pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à
Jean-Philippe Ardon merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues au nom du
groupe Renaissance je tiens tout d'abord
vous remercier pour votre travail et vos
conclusions sur les enjeux de notre
défense solaire comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République lors de ses
vœux aux armées le 20 janvier dernier à
Mont-de-Marsan la future loi de
programmation militaire sera
particulièrement ambitieuse à la fois
pour renforcer la protection de nos
intérêts nationaux dans les nouveaux
espaces de conflictualité pour
développer nos partenariats
internationaux mais également pour nous
réarmer et être en capacité d'assumer
les conflits de haute intensité
notre groupe salut à cet égard le choix
ambitieux d'investir 5 milliards d'euros
pour notre défense solaire dans la LPM
2024 2030 et d'en faire une capacité
prioritaire pour nos armées au même
titre que le spatial le cyber ou le
renseignement comme vous l'avez évoqué
le ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
a annoncé la livraison au printemps
prochain d'un système de défense solaire
de moyenne portée dénommé Mamba
construit en coopération avec l'Italie
pour aider l'Ukraine face aux attaques
de drone de missiles et d'avions russes
ce système présente de nombreuses
capacités avec notamment un champ
d'action supérieur à 100 km une
puissance de feu importante et une
grande mobilité
aussi quels sont à vos yeux les
avantages et les inconvénients de ce
système en comparaison de ceux de nos
alliés notamment le système patriotes
américains et le nassam Norvégien je
vous remercie merci beaucoup pour le
groupe rassemblement national la parole
est à Francky
sonore de votre rapport et même de la
qualité de votre apport merci nous tarde
le lire la guerre en Ukraine n'a fait
que confirmer un constat déjà bien
établi la défense solaire demeure l'un
des parents pauvres de l'armée de l'air
de l'espace comme de l'armée de terre
avec la révision générale des publics
des politiques publiques de 2008 la
décision avait été prise de scinder la
défense solaire en deux d'une part la
défense solaire de moyenne portée
d'imamba et courte portée crotale NG
pour ce qui concerne l'armée de l'air et
d'autre part la très courte portée
mistrale pour la méditer ces systèmes
sont performants mais en quantité très
limitée or l'armée de l'air est
confronté à deux difficultés non
seulement elle dispose d'un nombre trop
insuffisants de mandats crâtal vous
l'avez dit du fait de la mutation des
missions lui affairant mais elle peine à
recruter parmi ses rangs et à fidéliser
en effet avec lui Mamba et 12 crottes
l'armée de l'air doit assurer trois
missions la protection de ces bases
nucléaires ainsi que de la marine la
protection de points sensibles le
soutien en force terrestre et puis ce
que nous avons déployés en Roumanie pour
la défense solaire l'armée est devenue
totalement indépendante de l'armée de
l'air qui n'a pas les moyens d'assumer
cette mission dans un nouveau contexte
de haute intensité pour l'armée de terre
le problème émane du manque de système à
moyen de portée capable de manœuvrer au
niveau brigade des divisions tandis
qu'elle ne dispose d'aucune capacité de
détection il conviendrait dès lors
d'envisager de prendre certaines
orientations au premier rang desquels on
peut par exemple considérer impératif
d'augmenter la quantité de système
précités de poursuivre la modernisation
du mandat vous l'avez évoqué aussi de
donner également à l'armée de terre des
systèmes moyennes portés tels que le
rapide fire dont on sait déjà qu'ils
équiperont les bâtiments de la Marine
nationale d'augmenter aussi des
capacités de détection en basse altitude
des drones qu'il s'agisse de l'armée de
l'air ou de l'armée de terre ou encore
d'investir massivement dans les
munitions de tous ces systèmes qui
finalement n'existent qu'en nombre très
réduit
il faut être conscient qu'en plus des
missions militaires de protection de
projection l'armée de l'air va devoir
faire face à deux événements mondiaux
majeurs avec des moyens très suffisent
insuffisants pardon la Coupe du monde de
rugby en 2023 et les JO en 2024 il y a
donc urgence à acquérir de nouveaux
systèmes aujourd'hui pas plus l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace l'armée de terre
non les moyens de remplir les missions
que le nouveau contexte stratégique
exige la défense solaire ne peut et ne
doit être le parent pauvre de l'armée de
l'air de la terre dans cette perspective
votre rapport vous a-t-il permis de
déterminer si l'armée de l'air allait
conserver augmenter ses moyens actuels
pour continuer à aider l'armée de terre
ou s'il était préférable que chacune
d'elles dispose de ses propres moyens je
vous remercie merci pour le groupe la
France insoumise la parole est à
François pickman oui monsieur le
Président cher rapporteur merci déjà
pour pour ce rapport
je fais là je vais me contenter vu que
le temps est limité de poser directement
quelques questions qui me sont venues à
à votre écoute comment va se déployer la
défense solaire exactement
lors des grands événements ça a été
évoqué vous avez évoqué la Coupe du
monde de rugby mais il y a aussi
évidemment les Jeux Olympiques 2024
il y a-t-il d'autres requêtes mis à part
l'Ukraine sur lesquels vous êtes appuyé
pour ce rapport parce que peut-être que
ça m'a échappé mais je n'en ai je sais
pas entendu d'autres exemples et ça
m'aurait intéressé d'en avoir et enfin
quelle est la place du commandement de
l'espace actuel et peut-être futur dans
cette défense solaire je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe démocrates
la parole est à Fabien les
merci monsieur le Président et
félicitations au cours à porteur c'était
vraiment très intéressant de vous
entendre sur ce sujet qui
malheureusement si vous permettez cette
image et passer en dessous des radars
pendant des nombreuses années puisqu'on
a connu la tricition or
on voit aujourd'hui tous les enjeux et
vous les avez brillamment rappelés avec
des zooms particulièrement intéressants
je vais pas m'y éteindre mais sur sur
l'Europe de l'Est les besoins de leur en
matière d'Europe de l'Est sur le flanc
sud mais également la problématique des
planeurs je suis hypersoniques donc
merci d'avoir explicité tous ces
éléments bon malgré tout on peut quand
même se féliciter d'avoir une excellente
quoi beaucoup coopération avec l'Italie
avec le mamba SMPT qui l'un des
meilleurs systèmes de défense
antimissiles au monde donc c'est quand
même à mettre au crédit de la France et
de ses partenariats mais on voit
vraiment avec la guerre de l'Ukraine
vous l'avez parfaitement rappelé
la nécessité d'avoir un système de
défense
airsol particulièrement adapté pour
protéger nos intérêts vitaux et les
populations dans la mesure on peut le
faire vous l'avez très bien appelé aussi
bon comme tout système d'armement il est
important de garder donc un avantage
technologique sur nos concurrents et
actuellement une course mondiale est
engagée pour le développement de l'arme
laser en Israël le projet iron bean et
qui est intégré dans le système de
défense aérienne iron Dom vous n'avez
pas parlé tout à l'heure repose sur
l'utilisation de laser capable de
neutraliser des roquettes des mortiers
et des petits drones alors notre BITD
peut se féliciter d'avoir en son sein à
l'entreprise Silas situé à Orléans qui
se place en avant-poste dans le
développement des lasers l'entreprise
appartenant désormais à MBDA et Safran a
déjà pu développer collaboration et la
DG un système antidrone autonome c'est
ce type de technologie comporte de
nombreux aspects positifs par rapport au
système de défense solaire actuel elle
doit encore être soutenue dans son
développement à l'échelle française et
européenne pour espérer un jour pouvoir
se substituer alors quel constat
faites-vous sur la technologie laser
dans les systèmes de défense solaire
pour les années à venir merci merci pour
le groupe socialiste la parole est à
Mélanie Thomas
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues rapporteur je vous remercie
pour votre travail et pour la
présentation que vous venez de nous
faire si l'on en croit le ministre des
Armées la défense solaire représentera 5
milliards d'euros dans la prochaine LPM
toutes couches confondues la
disponibilité de ces équipements et leur
performances apparaît critique pour
assurer non seulement notre propre
défense mais aussi pour la projection
d'une assistance éventuelle à nos alliés
à ce titre nous voyons que ces systèmes
participent à maintenir la contestation
de l'espace aérien sur le théâtre
ukrainien bien que l'incapacité russe à
mettre en oeuvre des manœuvres des
manoeuvres interarmes il joue pour
beaucoup également
lors de la présentation de la revue
nationale stratégique le président avait
déclaré que la défense solaire ne
pouvait se résumer à la promotion d'une
industrie nationale ou d'industrie
tierce aux dépens de la souveraineté
européenne nous lisons en creux la
déception face à l'initiative européenne
mais j'ai peine à y voir une stratégie
qui puisse parler à nos partenaires
européens
si le conflit ukrainien a mis la défense
au cœur des priorités européennes il n'a
évidemment pas favorisé une souveraineté
européenne qui n'est pas mature
stratégiquement et industriellement pour
répondre aux besoins immédiats c'est
donc l'achat sur étagère notamment
américain qui est privilégié et
peut-être face à ce constat cher
collègue Thiriot j'avais lu lors de
votre déplacement en Pologne vos propos
vous y dénonciez la tentation
hégémonique allemande et je vous entends
à nouveau aujourd'hui lorsque vous dites
que pour coopérer il faut être plusieurs
vous parler aussi de l'aveuglement
allemand et je ne pars pas des mêmes
constats
je pars des mêmes constats pardon sans
partager votre analyse aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne est dans un refus de
leadership elle ne cherche pas à imposer
sa vision stratégique pour l'instant
elle annonce des moyens en religant la
politique de défense et les doctrines
d'emploi au cadre hôtel
à ce titre il semble curieux d'opposer
nos partenaires d'Europe de l'Est et
l'Allemagne alors quelle analyse
faites-vous actuellement du rapport de
force européen et quelle sera la marge
de manœuvre non seulement de nos
industriels mais aussi des futurs
projets de coopération dans un contexte
de poursuite de la guerre
merci il nous reste deux questions et je
compte sur la brièveté des orateurs la
parole est à Julien grand cool
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs donc tout
d'abord je tiens à vous remercier pour
votre travail ces rapports me paraissent
vraiment utile pour que les
parlementaires s'emparent des sujets
plus spécifiques liés à la défense comme
il a été annoncé récemment par le
Président et par le ministre 5 milliards
d'euros vont être investis dans la
défense solaire cela peut paraître
beaucoup mais en réalité c'est 5
milliards arrivant après des décennies
où la défense solaire a été abandonnée
pourtant elle a été primordiale pour
protéger nos bases aériennes et encore
nous et plus encore nos territoires
d'outre-mer qui ont besoin de garanties
de sécurité en raison de leur
éloignement des plus importantes
capacités de nos forces dans le cadre de
notre travaux liés sur la défense
solaire est-il ressorti l'idée qu'il
fallait que notre défunte solaire
s'équipe également de système de
contre-mesure quand on pense à un
système solaire on pense souvent aux
missile et au radars mais on évoquera
romain les systèmes de contre-mesure
comme les leurs le paradigme de haute
intensité ou la tricion de nos munitions
seraient massive conduit-il selon vous à
envisager un système de défense solaire
où les leurs prendraient une place plus
importante pour compléter notre arsenal
de défense je vous remercie merci enfin
la parole est à Jean-Marie
merci monsieur le Président merci chers
courant porteur dans un contexte où
l'Allemagne a initié un système commun
de défense aérienne et antimissile
dénommé européenne scale shell avec 15
pays membres de l'OTAN sur 30 qu'en
est-il de l'interobabilité actuelle des
systèmes d'armes en matière de défense
seul r dans l'OTAN et comment renforcer
cette interro perrabilité indispensable
à notre défense je vous remercie je fais
très court merci pour la brièveté
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs vous
avez la parole pour une dizaine de
minutes maximum
alors j'irai vite et je rassemblerai les
questions concernant le mandat ses
performances effectivement vous les vous
avez dit s'ils ont des performances dans
le domaine moyenne portée qui sont
qui sont excellentes et qui qui sont
tout à fait comparables à celle du
Patriote
je peux dire le somme t actuel et
comparable au Patriote qui est
majoritairement livré dans ces versions
majoritairement livrées en
Europe et l'évolution du sante solaire
moyenne portée donc appeler Mamba pour
la version terrestre NG pour nouvelle
génération et comparable aux versions
les plus évoluées du Patriote en ce qui
concerne le NASA c'est des pâtes tout à
fait le même système alors on le classe
en longue portée parfois parce que c'est
un missile qui est plus longue portée
mais le système n'est pas plus long
porté au contraire il intervient à
il peut intercepter des cibles à à
plutôt à bas attitude ou disons moyenne
altitude contrairement au Patriote et et
au santé Mamba qui eux ont un
intercepteur moyenne haute altitude donc
on ne parle pas du tout de du même type
de système et d'ailleurs le santé
aura aussi cette capacité d'aller
intercepter un peu plus un peu plus haut
et de façon un peu plus anticipée des
missiles balistiques qui lorsqu'il
rentre dans dans l'atmosphère et donc ce
que n'a pas le système nasame je crois
que c'était l'essentiel pour pour le
santé
je passe la parole peut-être à mon
collègue qui va répondre aux questions
de
je pense
2 je ne sais pas
je vais répondre brièvement sur la
question posée par Monsieur Giletti
on essaie de faire vite absolument
concernant défense
rapport Armée de l'Air armée de terre je
crois réellement et on l'a vu dans
d'autres pays qui n'ont pas encore
arbitré que d'avoir l'unité de
commandement c'est-à-dire un chef une
mission des moyens concernant la
troisième dimension et pilotée par
l'armée de l'air est aujourd'hui un
système qui fonctionne et qui fonctionne
bien je dis ça en termes de commandement
et d'attribution des zones à protéger en
revanche et c'est ce que j'évoquais à
travers le renforcement de la défense
solaire bascouche et notamment la
protection du corps de bataille on a un
besoin de renforcement
de la volumétrie mistrale concernant les
efflecteurs de la volumétrie canon qui
n'existe plus d'avoir des C2 adaptés au
box
qui sont attribués à l'armée de terre
parce qu'il faut bien voir aujourd'hui
c'est que dans une zone déterminée
l'Armée de l'Air dit cette zone
sermetaire est-ce que on a besoin
d'avoir des missiles moyennes portées à
disposition de l'armée de terre très
franchement si l'armée de l'air on a
assez non si l'armée de l'air n'en a pas
assez oui voilà la question je crois
qu'aujourd'hui avec le renforcement qui
est c'est pas la priorité en tout cas ne
compliquons pas les
les relations entre les deux mais oui
l'armée terre doit être absolument
renforcée dans le segment bascouche pour
répondre à notre collègue de LFI
sur les grands événements pas
d'information particulière à dire si ce
n'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un C2 qui est
prévu et où la totalité des opérateurs
c'est-à-dire civils je pense notamment à
la préfecture de police
armée de l'air et armée de terre sont
engagés sous pilotage sur votre question
ROTEX évidemment l'Ukraine nous a
interpellé pas que les événements
en arcade qu'en Arménie ont évidemment
fait l'objet d'un suivi étroit et puis
d'autres conflits plus classiques par
exemple la guerre du Golfe j'avais
évoqué la guerre du Kippour ou le
Vietnam qui ont aussi leur intérêt par
exemple la guerre du Golfe a montré
l'importance des missiles
anti-radar l'Ukraine les a aussi un peu
montré mes différemment parce qu'il y
avait une agilité plus grande des unités
ukrainiennes donc oui tout ça a été
intégré à notre réflexion
oui monsieur Piquemal pour pour répondre
à votre question là par rapport à la
protection des grands événements
effectivement comme l'anime au collègue
il y a une entente entre préfecture de
police de Paris pour ce qui est de Paris
et puis bien sûr
les l'armée de l'air qui va qui ensemble
vont combiner ce qu'on appelle une
vision de l'espace aérien partagé single
air picture donc tout ça est en voie de
développement et quasiment abouti et
bien sûr il y aura une répartition
des systèmes de défense solaire en
fonction des grands sites en fonction
des points sensibles
à protéger et
il y aura une déclinaison des moyens
très courte portée qui seront
essentiellement donc sur le terrain
puisqu'on va être en zone urbaine
essentiellement qui seront
fait grâce au système parade on l'a
abordé rapidement tout à l'heure donc
vous avez des fusils brouilleurs enfin
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de voir tout ça à
l'exercice Coubertin qui a été mené
début février et et on pourra bien sûr
en avoir une illustration plus complète
lors de la Coupe du monde de rugby et
comme rétexte il y a eu aussi la Coupe
du Monde au
Qatar Coupe du monde de football au
Qatar ou la France avait envoyé des
systèmes bassaltes
oui pour finir avec notre collègue
Picmal sur le commandement de l'espace
je dirais ça viendra aujourd'hui la
France
ne dispose pas ou peu de moyens spacieux
permettant de détecter des départs à
très longue distance donc c'est un des
sujets de fond c'est une des questions
liées à twister et un réseau d'alerte
spatial aujourd'hui c'est pas au cœur de
la DSA en tout cas dans les segments
qu'on avait évoqué puisqu'on a exclu les
ICBM sur l'antidrone et le laser
évidemment ça fait partie des outils
essentiels face au drone il y a
plusieurs moyens on l'a brièvement
évoqué soit embrouille mais ça suppose
des drones téléguidés aujourd'hui on
peut avoir des drones qui travaillent
avec des centrales à inertiels des
centrales inertielles premier sujet
autre solution la cinétique ont détruit
troisième solution on grille les
le circuit électronique où on le détruit
par chauffage le laser est un des outils
permettant la destruction
du drone au stade où on aime et ça va
évoluer très vite ça nécessite quand
même de maintenir un faisceau
suffisamment longtemps sur la cible on
n'a pas nécessairement l'énergie et
surtout ça dépend des conditions météo
donc l'autre aspect est probablement de
brûler les circuits à travers des armes
énergies dirigées avant qu'on ait ce
type de laser je vais répondre à notre
collègue sur le sujet allemand parce que
c'est un des sujets qui me paraît
vraiment important et puis après je
laisse il y a d'autres sujets puisque on
m'a dit qu'il fallait finir à 55 donc on
finira à midi
voilà ça s'appelle les 5 minutes de
courtoisie je pense que vous avez sur
interprété mes propos
je nos amis allemands ont un
comportement objectivement peu amical
une fois qu'on a dit ça la réalité c'est
qu'au cœur de l'Europe on a un pays
l'Allemagne qui est là qui est un
partenaire historique et personne
aujourd'hui
n'envisage de ne pas travailler avec les
Allemands alors face à ce projet du
européen de ski
il est fou pardonnez-moi qu'on est même
pas
interroger MBDA sur ce projet donc
prenons-en acte que les pays qui
souhaitent participer à ce projet y
participent et nous continuons il y a
pas de vision stratégique allemande dans
cette affaire quand vous dites que les
Allemands n'ont pas de volonté de
leadership on a surtout des Allemands
aujourd'hui qui ont une difficulté
politique liée à la coalition Apple
puisqu'on sait même que sur les sujets
de défense ils sont loin d'être d'accord
ce qui en fait d'ailleurs partenaire
compliqué parce que on a parfois des
allers-retours on a des discours sur la
première puissance
conventionnelle du
continent après on a des retours en
arrière mais je vous renvoie au discours
du général sortn et cela posait on a
aujourd'hui une autre puissance qui
souhaite prendre le leadership sur la
défense conventionnelle en Europe qui
sont nos alliés polonais qui font des
investissements absolument massifs en
matière de défense et qui sont de nature
à jouer aussi ce rôle donc je crois que
la nature de la France puissance dès
qu'il libres avec un S c'est aussi de
discuter avec tous nos partenaires et
notamment de renouer avec la Pologne un
lien important n'oublions jamais les
alliances de revers c'est toujours ce
qui dans le cadre amical de l'Union
européenne et aussi ce qui permet
d'équilibrer les puissance donc oui
rapprochons-nous des Polonais mais ils
sont pas dans l'Européen de skyfield ils
sont pas non plus dans des projets
européens puisque aujourd'hui ils ont la
menace russe à leur porte et ils ont
besoin d'une chose c'est des missiles
vite et fort des radars vite et fort et
malheureusement les capacités de
production l'abbéité des européennes ne
permet pas d'y répondre mais en tout cas
l'Allemagne c'est notre allié c'est
notre partenaire mais ça n'empêche pas
d'avoir des liens étroits avec d'autres
qu'on avait probablement négligé au
profit d'un tandem alors qu'il faut
penser à l'Europe médiane davantage il
faut penser à l'Europe du Sud et faire
un couple à 3 à 4 ou à 5 finalement ça
peut ne pas être mal
Nathalie a un dernier mot
oui et puis
pour quand même un peu je dirais
étoffer cette vision il y a quand même
des hauts et des bas dans toute
coopération on le sait très bien et
l'enjeu principal ça reste d'arriver à
concilier la réponse court terme à la
situation pressante et la préparation de
l'avenir et dans la préparation d'avenir
on a peut-être pas assez insisté mais il
y a les enjeux de marché effectivement
il faut s'ouvrir des potentiels de
marché et pour ça il y a la
standardisation mais il faut compter
bien évidemment sur nos forces et on a à
travers
MBDA une un missilié de premier plan un
système et de premier plan et donc à
nous de
continuer la promotion de nos systèmes
et pour les systèmes à venir de
s'assurer qu'ils seront bien tous je
veux dire
à des standards européens c'est un c'est
un c'est un combat il faut il faut le
mener
je passerai rapidement à la dernière
question je pense de monsieur rancoul
qui a posé une question très pertinente
sur les contre-mesures effectivement ça
a été très peu abordé vous avez parlé de
l'heure moi je pense aussi aux
brouillage surtout et je pense que voilà
il faut effectivement investir
réinvestir dans tout le potentiel que la
guerre électronique peut fournir et et
et dans l'autre sens on sait très bien
aussi que par exemple les missiles en
tiradar vont vont essayer de
contrecarrer la défense donc il y a
toujours les l'histoire de de l'armée du
bouclier mais vous l'avez raison il ne
faut pas
oublier négliger les contre-mesures et
notamment la guerre électrode bien
écoutez merci à tous les deux pour votre
travail et la complémentaire de votre
binôme qui a permis la rencontre
j'allais dire de du chiffre de
l'ingénieur et de la lettre de l'auteur
première collègues je vais maintenant
vous demander si vous autorisez la
publication de ce rapport à ce qu'il y a
des abstentions des oppositions je n'en
vois aucune je vous remercie et je vous
remercie également en tant que
rapporteur pour ce